It is great to welcome back to the program
Congressman Roe Connor, who represents California's
17th District, located in the heart of Silicon
Valley.
Great to have you back, Congressman.
Appreciate it.
David, I appreciate your show.
I appreciated your show during the burning
campaign and look forward to coming on as
often as you'll have me.
Yes.
Well, we will talk about the Bernie campaign.
But in terms of where we are now, we're it
looks like Joe Biden will.
He said he will announce his V.P. pick around
August 1st is the latest that I've seen.
You like Elizabeth Warren as Joe Biden's possible
V.P..
Why?
I do.
I mean, I obviously I thought Bernie Sanders
would have been the ideal person to lead us
at this time.
I was a co-chair of his campaign.
And the reason is that Bernie Sanders understood
the importance of movement politics.
He understood that you don't achieve anything
just having smart people in Washington and
good policy.
You need to have a mobilized base.
And I saw the passion that he inspired, particularly
among young people that said he's not going
to be the nominee.
And obviously, he's not going to be in consideration
for Vice President Joe Biden said he wants
to have a woman on the ticket.
And in that circumstance, it's obvious to
me that the most progressive possibility is
Elizabeth Warren.
She's also exceedingly competent.
I mean, when I have worked with her, she really
understands federal agencies.
She really understands how the Senate works,
how the House works.
And in fact, I had recommended when it looked
like Bernie Sanders was going to be possibly
the nominee, that he pick Elizabeth Warren,
given her expertize and knowledge of the federal
government and her commitment to progressive
ideals.
So I think for the same reason, she would
be very good for Vice President Biden and
Morse.
Urgent, given we need a true progressive in
that there is often these conventional wisdoms,
which very often or not are not really that
wise about.
You know, you need to think about what part
of the country you're V.P. is from in terms
of appealing maybe to Southerners or Midwesterners
or, you know, having a strategy that appeals
more broadly than a northeastern Democrat.
However, the latest polling I've seen suggests
that Elizabeth Warren may actually be the
option that gives Joe Biden the largest polling
boost.
Is this something unique about Warren in your
mind, or is the the dynamic this time around
just so different that those conventional
wisdoms maybe don't apply?
You know, it's I've never been a big fan of
that conventional wisdom thinking, and it's
convenient now, it doesn't apply when you
have a Bill Clinton and Al Gore, when you
have sort of moderate tickets, it seems OK.
OK.
Let's double down.
My view is that the vice presidential pick
should be someone who people will see as a
governing partner.
Even though I totally disagreed with them,
I thought Bush's pick of Dick Cheney was very
strategically smart at the time.
People were questioning his competence to
lead on foreign policy.
And he was sort of reassuring people saying,
look, I've got this person, Cheney.
And so in this case, I think people are going
to ask the question, who is going to be able
to help rebuild the economy?
Who is going to really understand competence
in government?
And under those metrics, I think Elizabeth
Warren really stands out.
And I think that's one of the reasons you're
seeing the polling.
The second reason you're seeing the polling
is a lot of younger voters and voters of color
actually support her policies that are for
a green new deal, for Medicare for all.
Therefore, free public college, they're most
affected by student loans.
So you're seeing that she has a lot of support
and across the board with Democrats, but also
young voters.
And finally, and this is no detraction from
other candidates.
The fact is that she has a tight, trusted
brand.
Right.
So, I mean, if you were to poll Elizabeth
worth it more and me, you know, even though
I have all the policies, Warren would be overwhelmingly
liked because people trust her.
They know her.
And I think at a time of crisis, that matters.
And so just the fact of her familiarity, while
I may not be an advantage in a different election
year, I think in this election year, really
a place to her benefit.
There is a contingent of those who supported
Bernie Sanders.
I don't know what the size of it is.
I know.
If you spend a lot of time online, it feels
bigger.
If you spend more time, you know, in Ohio
knocking, it probably feels smaller of people
that supported Bernie that are not looking
like they are interested in voting for Joe
Biden.
And I've addressed this before.
I'm not planning to shame anybody for their
vote.
If someone genuinely feels that they'd rather
four more years of Trump than Biden, by all
means, they should act in accordance with
that.
But for those who are looking to either punish
the DNC or send a message or any of these
other things, do you have a message to that
contingent of those who were with you during
the primary with Bernie?
Sure.
I'd say do it in other ways.
I mean, if you want to run progressive challengers
to people in the House or the Senate, even
if I can't support it, I appreciate that and
understand that if you want to have a challenge
to the DNC, I appreciate that and support
that.
If you want to make sure that in in in twenty,
twenty four we have a progressive nominee,
even if, you know, it's getting behind whoever,
even if it's not the vice president.
Fine.
I support that.
But don't sabotage the progressive movement
by having four more years of Trump in.
And that's the reason that's a sabotages,
mostly.
Partly because of the courts.
I mean, let's assume Bernie Sanders, who knows
if he runs again, let's say he became president
in 2024.
You know, I mean, in four years, Alder's,
early 80s and we had eight years of Trump.
I mean, what could Bernie Sanders do in a
Supreme Court that was seven to two against
us in agencies that have been totally.
Got it.
He would basically basically be a bridge president,
then trying to fix the Supreme Court and trying
to undo the damage.
And it would take another 10 years before
the we had progressive policy.
On the other hand, let's say we had Joe Biden
and then in twenty four we had Bernie Sanders
or a progressive.
You know that then you're at least having
more forward progress.
So I'm for a pragmatic about it, but I agree.
Ultimately, I think the vote is sacred and
we have to earn people's vote not to sort
of badger them into supporting the ticket.
And so you it sounds like you don't subscribe
to the more acceleration is the ideas of sometimes
you've got to burn it down to build it back
up or Trump being who Trump is, will accelerate
some much more progressive leftward swing.
I mean, I guess it didn't seem to happen over
the last four years in the sense that Joe
Biden and ended up the nominee ultimately.
But that doesn't sound like a philosophy you
subscribe to.
I guess I guess it's a philosophy of a bit
of privilege, right?
I mean, even if it were true and who knows
if it were if it were true that there is going
to be some opposite reaction.
Are we willing to sacrifice the kids in cages
in the meantime, or are we willing to sacrifice
the Muslim American Muslims who are not allowed
into this country?
Are we willing to sacrifice?
The environmental damage that's happening
every day.
Are we willing to sacrifice the court?
So it seems to me not consistent with progressive
ideals of every life matters and that the
ends don't justify the means.
I also don't think it's necessarily true.
I mean, I think that Trump will do so much
damage in stoking racial division and stoking
xenophobia that if he has eight years left
at the next president, that's probably going
to have to do a lot of cleanup and isn't going
to be in a position as easily of pushing bold,
progressive ideas.
Whereas if you have Biden, the next president
after him could do that.
We essentially agree.
So let's let's move on to to another topic
that I want to talk about, which is the sort
of next six to 12 months related to Corona
virus.
I think one of the worst things that could
happen would be sort of overlapping openings
and closures meant to try to try to play whack
a mole while we still have no effective treatment
and we still wait for for a vaccine.
What are you sort of thinking is the most
likely trajectory over the next six months,
given what we're seeing at the state level
right now and federal leadership on the virus?
Well, I appreciate your saying that.
I mean, first we have to look at what could
have been not you look at countries like South
Korea.
Now, South Korea did things about compromising
people's privacy, which we would never do
here.
But they get some very simple things.
They told everyone to wear masks right in
the beginning.
Our CDC was going back and forth on that.
They had us testing out there and they work
even with private sector testing companies.
Our government was arrogant to reject not
only W World Health Organization's tests,
but also to reject the private sector's help
in testing.
So and we should have had a lockdown much
earlier.
I called for a national lockdown in March.
And if we had done that for a couple of weeks,
we would have avoided some of the the the
the deaths, even New York.
And I don't want to cast blame on any particular
leaders, but if they had locked down when
Santa Clara County did, the former CDC head
estimates that, you know, almost 80 percent
of deaths could have been avoided.
All of this is to say that these should be
lessons going forward.
And my view going forward is that we ought
to have a clear national guidelines on where
we need for masks, where we need for social
distancing, where we need policies in terms
of non gathered, not gathering and in large
areas.
I understand locally people can then determine
whether whether to start some business or
not.
But I think there has to be some national
guidelines as well.
And then we need a greater focus on on testing
and a greater focus on the adoption.
You know, Google, Apple, it is my district.
They've come up with this app.
It would be voluntary in terms of people display
disclosing their information and the information
would be private.
But I think we need to try to get them more
adopted.
I think that could help.
I want to talk about testing in a moment,
but let's talk about the earlier lockdown
briefly.
What was the date that Santa Clara lockdown,
do you remember offhand?
March, March 16th, 16th.
Okay, so that's a little.
I've said that somewhere between March 5th
and 15th.
We had nearly 100 hundred cases in China.
Italy already was around four to six thousand
and we had several hundred cases.
That to me, seems like it would have been
enough information for Donald Trump to say
this is going to be tough, but I need all
50 governors with me.
We need 30 days of stay at home.
It probably would have had to be extended
another 30.
It would have ended on May 5th.
Like that 60 day period could have been over
by May 5th or May 10th or May 15th.
And when I mentioned this to Joe Rogan last
week, he said there was no app.
You wouldn't have gotten anybody to do it
on March 5th or 10th or 15th because there
was no appetite for it.
Doesn't that miss that 40 percent of the country
will essentially agree with whatever Donald
Trump proposes and maybe it actually could
have been done at that earlier stage?
It actually could have been done.
I mean, Dr. Sarah Cody, who did this on March
30th, she had the benefit of being married
to an epidemiologist at Stanford who told
her that every single day that you wait, you're
actually creating exponential risk.
And that's why she convinced the six payor
counties to shelter in place in Santa Clara
County, which was one of the earliest hit,
has only had about one hundred and twenty
deaths as a result of hard her decision.
So and they complied very strongly.
People in my district have complied.
I believe Trump had done that.
People would have complied.
I have no doubt about it.
And my guess is he probably would have made
that decision in retrospect, because it would
have put him in a better position for reelection
if he could have done that in March and come
April, in mid April or May.
We had avoided the worst of it and the economy
was reopening.
I think he underestimated how severe this
was going to be, how long it was going to
last.
And, you know, it's a little bit of Monday
morning quarterbacking, but I think when it
really shows is the need not just for us to
listen to science, that's everyone says that
and that's the easy part.
But how do you create a culture where we communicate
science in a way that speaks to people's lived
experience and isn't rejected?
And what is that dialog and communication
and how do we facilitate that?
And I and I think we have large questions
in our democracy to understand that because
climate change, so many of these issues are
going to raise similar questions where your
intuition is contradicting scientific information.
And how do we act in that in those cases?
This is one of the things I talked about earlier
this week, that scary, which is that what
is really a medical situation has become a
proxy culture war where it's about tyranny
and liberty.
It's about the mask as a political signal.
And it's completely divorced from from the
scientific reality.
And I understand like tomorrow on the show,
I'm going to do a hypothetical, what would
be a good reason for a left wing skepticism
of a total lockdown?
And it's going to be a sort of very careful
examination of different elements of this.
But the way in which this has become a culture
war that is divorced from science is seems
acutely disturbing.
I agree with that.
And I think we on the left have to be careful,
too, because I think when we start the conversation
with people on the right don't believe in
science, I think it puts people in a defensive
posture.
Right.
And I think that there's probably.
Here's what I think is actually going on.
I mean, this is just a bit speculation, but
my sense is that people just have different
probabilities of risk and different tolerance
for death and different tolerance for economic
decline.
And what you're really seeing is a conflict
of those values.
So I don't think people on on the right are
out there saying, well, we don't believe that
a small minority, but the vast majority are
not saying we don't believe call it exists
or is being transmitted or that masks how.
But they're saying, you know, the probability
is so small and get on with it.
And we're rugged and tough.
And this is what we're going to do.
It's a question as a democracy is how do we
have the conversation to be more about the
clash of values, which is really where it
is, and a given take rather than the politicization
of science.
And I think what you're seeing is the politicization
of science is really about a clash of values.
So people are trying to politicize science
to have their value that the economics matter
more than saving certain lives.
Last thing I want to touch on in terms of
testing, what is the number of daily tests
that you believe is where we should be?
It what from what I'm seeing?
If we don't get to five hundred thousand a
day, there's not really even very much to
talk about.
But that.
Right.
It's got to be somewhere between one and a
half and five million tests a day.
Where do you have a sense that that's what
I've heard from Fouchier from from the CDC
that, you know, I've heard ideally it would
be a million tests a day, but short of that,
around four to five million a week.
I think that would be important.
But it's not just the testing.
It's then what do you do with the testing
and what are you doing in terms of contact
tracing?
What are you doing in terms of isolating these
individuals?
What are you doing in terms of testing the
right people that they're testing folks who
are in packed circumstances or central workers?
So.
Yes, we need more capacity for testing.
But when you look at a country like South
Korea and they didn't do everything right,
they had violations of civil liberties.
But because of their Saar's experience, they
had a lot of cultural norms about what they
will do with the testing and who did test
and how to contact Crace.
And hopefully our country will develop some
of that having gone through this experience.
Yeah, certainly it's not just the testing,
but the testing is it's it's necessary, but
not sufficient, I guess is the point that
you're that you're and that's just that's
a succinct way to say what I was trying to
say.
We've been speaking with Congressman Roe Cano,
who represents California's 17th District.
Congressman, always great having you on.
I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.